this is bangkok's first governor
election since the coup that brought the
military to power in 2013.
the military removed the previous
elected governor in 2016 to install
police general assoin quan wong in the
job now he says he's running as an
independent candidate though many still
see him as the chosen nominee of the
military
i want to continue serving the people
it's common to run for an office for
another term i know that i was appointed
but now i want to be elected
guan wong's perceived closeness to the
coup leaders may cost him at the polls
his main rival engineer and former
minister chad
point
enjoys wide support among young people
who filled the streets on many occasions
to protest against the military coup and
demand reform he says he has a vision
for a more modernized more prosperous
capital
it doesn't matter if you're an
independent candidate or backed by
political parties the governor has to
remove his allegiance to a political
party and has to try his or her best to
take care of the people
city points young supporters who failed
to have their demands met through
protests see this election as a likely
opportunity for change they don't want
to miss it
this is a mall where there is a huge
crackdown on young protesters it's
probably the first clash between
protesters and police officers do you
think that those kids who came out to
fight on the street would not come out
to vote
i think it will show that young people
care about politics and they are aware
of what's going on they are not just
someone who hides behind the keyboard it
is time for us to choose who should lead
us and how the city will move forward
the last bangkok governor election was
in 2013
and for nine years opposition voters
have been waiting for a day like this
hoping it will allow them to get by the
ballot box what was denied them by force
since the military coup muhammad